a knock on the door I open it it's the
cop so I'm like Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
one of my favorite comments to watch you
guys lobster lovers give it up for mr.
Traeger you guys where I was just a dumb
bitch who couldn't stop getting arrested
I just wanted to be in jail all the time
so the story starts at Iowa State
University where I went to follow my one
true passion in life advertising so I
show up as a fresh-faced teen just being
like I'm gonna make commercials
um I hated everybody I did not fit in at
all they made me live in an agriculture
dorm so it was just like all these girls
who had pictures of their farm animals
that were their friends that they that
like won contests with and then ate
later in the evening at a restaurant
called the machine shed so who I didn't
get along with them and then I just
didn't connect with anybody like on my
18th birthday in college I had no
friends so I just went got my nipples
pierced cuz I thought like this is a way
to like commemorate the time but like
that that is how lonely I was that I
just went alone and just like Yap here
some dude and then I try to that
guy didn't work out he like Jesus but I
tried you like look kind of tough and so
I was lonely I didn't have friends like
my number one hobby became racquetball
go 50 year-old Asian and I was the
treasurer of the Juke lot like nothing
was really happening like I couldn't
find a friend they couldn't find a
passion and so I just like started
drinking a lot and obviously that's what
everyone does in college but yeah I just
got blacked out constantly all the time
and then this one night my friend she
was having some friends over
I remember hooking up with someone in
her bed and then I had a bump on my head
but I don't remember how and then I just
took a nap on the couch and my friends
all knew that I loved drinking and
driving so they hid my car keys
so I went I know people are like really
anti drinking and driving but this was
like 10 years ago so you all got silent
who has DUIs here how many of you yeah
okay hey guys
well yeah I was just like a fun thing to
do so like I run it around I found the
keys and I went drinking and driving and
but I was driving to my house and then I
was like I could I was just right by my
house and then I was like I want Burger
King so I kept driving and two blocks
from my house I get pulled over and I
just act like the dumb white bitch I am
and I'm just like my know my rights I am
a lawyer like calling my dad I mean like
I'm not drunk but like yeah it's a
problem so they take me to jail they put
me in the drunk tank which I'm kind of
into cuz I love the aquarium and I felt
like I was in one so I was like okay
with that and I did feel really bad
about myself drunk driving sucks you can
kill like it was really an embarrassing
sad time in my life and I was like
things need to change I need to become a
better person
so I went to AAA and then I was like oh
I'm better than everyone here so so I
never went back to a but you know I was
like depressed and yeah just like really
introspective I probably read some books
or two and I was really trying hard to
be sober and not be like a wild gal and
my friend Shannon at the time she had a
lot of problems too she was trying to be
sober now we all know it's because she
was a lesbian and she was like hiding
her true self you know name means like
but we all should have known she had
this ponytail that was like gelled
really tight with like right in the
middle of the head you know like no
casual girl loves soccer that much
so he should have known but so she was
having weird problems like figuring
herself out I obviously was not in the
right place in life but wasn't mature
enough to be like I need to get out of
here and she called me one day this was
three weeks after the first arrest and
she went hey do you want to have a sober
night out and we'll go to the gymnastics
meet we had an amazing gymnastics team
and I was like absolutely so we I went
to her dorm room and before we went to
the gymnastics meet she went I mean we
should have one drink
I was like yes so the next thing I know
the bottle of parrot Bay is gone and I'm
not sure what kind of liquor it is but
it's clear and there's a fun bird on it
we drank it and then I just remember us
just wanting more and still like we're
walking through the girls side of the
dorm just like getting as much booze as
we can and then I remember my crush on
this woodsy boy like he lived in the
dorm as well so like we got a visit
woodsy and so we so we go to his dorm
and this is the thing like I was pretty
drunk so don't remember the exact
details but I just remember everyone's
face of disappointment like nobody
wanted us there and we were just like
you know just classic drunk girls a lot
of leaning and complimenting and then
next thing I know Shannon is bleeding
full-on all the way all both her it just
blood everywhere and because I knew she
was depressed I'm like clearly she's
trying to kill herself so I started
running up and down the dorms just like
Shannon's trying to kill herself call
9-1-1 she's committing suicide call the
police
um but she wasn't trying to kill herself
she was just having a good time punching
through the fire extinguisher glass so
like my bad um just a goof you know so
we get back to the dorms we clean her
off she's laying life goes on a knock on
the door I open it it's the cops so I'm
like oh no thank you
[Music]
so I just closes the door in their face
but it's like flimsy dorm doors so
they're able to come in and easily and I
just start shoving these men I'm just
like no thank you
you know just like no no just as all my
my you're like yeah thank goodness your
way you know you would not be here today
and I feel the same way and so I'm just
shoving these guys I'm doing em they
finally like get me into the hallway and
go into the dorm to help Shannon and I
just start screaming kick him kick him
kick him just she's kicking these cops
and I'm screaming in the hallway and I'm
sure the cops were like we're trying to
help a girl trying to kill herself
you know like what is that like I'm sure
they're like oh we're doing the Lord's
work or whatever that someone's trying
to kill themselves and these bitches are
just yelling kicking and shoving them so
the cops are actually very very nice to
me and they're like hey we know you're
having a wild night it's fine just call
a friend if you have any sober friends
to pick you up you don't have to go to
jail but it's the middle of Iowa on a
weekend no one's sober okay what
do you thought there's horses on the
campus we're bored okay there's nothing
to do so none of my friends were sober
so I had to go to jail and as soon as I
figured that out I just instead of being
like won't please please please I went
if you were smart you'd be a detective
you should have gone to college you
hillbilly trash you just couldn't try
like graduate from high school you
losers
so they handcuffed me pretty tight and
then to really like stick it to them I
went limp and they had to drag me into
the police car and they took Shannon off
to the hospital and I go I'm in jail
again and then I wake up in the middle
of the night Shannon is in jail so
Shannon why are you in jail she was
throwing bedpans at people at the
hospital now we're both in jail my
sister you know back home in Skokie
finds out about this you know I call her
her and her husband drive ten hours in a
blizzard to Iowa to bail me out of jail
and they're like you clearly don't know
how to live on your own so you're
dropping we're taking you home and then
they got me a Big Mac so full circle I
finally got my cheeseburger at the end
you know but so we go back home and then
I followed my next true passion in life
data-entry and it was so depressing um
so I was working in data entry and I got
a really bad haircut with layers with
blonde hair and they over texturized it
so that's upsetting and then I was
living in my parents house and just so
sad so I just like I didn't learn my
ways I just kept drinking so much and I
just kept being a mess to society and
then it was the White Sox home opener
and this is the year after they won the
World Series so this was an exciting day
and when they went to the World Series I
got acrylic black nails that said white
socks and white letters with diamonds on
them so like you can imagine and so we
are pumped it's my friend's 21st
birthday we are going to the White Sox
game this is a whole new life we're back
in Chicago you know and I got arrested
third inning I know you're all
you're all wondering oh my god what did
you do to get arrested I don't know no
idea all I remember is the same faces of
disappointment as the party and the dorm
room and just like everywhere and so as
I came to from my blackout they let me
out on my own recognizance which no I
was so drunk and all I could remember is
my friend's address and she lived at 420
I got in the cabinet
take me to 420 sir and so we went to 420
and I'm sorry this is so embarrassing I
didn't pay him okay I just ran away and
so I was like grappling whether it be
honest or not but we're here so I didn't
I ran away and and I get to my friend's
house and the whole time I'm thinking
like oh I'm gonna get so much sympathy
oh I'm so sad I keep getting arrested
poor me I'm a merman anis you know and
she's midway through an abortion pill
yeah yeah gasps some of you don't know
you can have at home abortion
so she's midway through an abortion and
so then I had to give her attention what
a
so annoying um but you know I haven't
been to jail since so it's been 11 years
thank you yeah and I guess the lesson of
this truly is no matter how bad life
gets just know that someone's at home in
the middle of an abortion so it could be
we're sorry thanks so much
[Applause]
[Music]